today we will be playing the hardest
game in the entire world
it's hard see this kid smashing his
iphone it's because of this game i think
don't fact check it
there's gonna be rage everybody just be
quiet i'm trying to concentrate emotion
this video will be epic okay so does
everyone have the game
yes yeah yes you walk to the right and
you try to avoid traps let's all do the
first level real quick
oh that sounds easy so see those three
blocks everybody yeah
yeah jump on the first one oh i missed i
made it i made the first one
i watched pewdiepie play this a long
time ago
i've already lost three lives i've lost
two
hmm it would help if i jumped and
there's spikes on the third block of
course should i wait at this level for
you to catch up
ah crap
[Music]
oh oh oh almost got it oh no what
ah i made it
i hate you yes okay i made it i made it
jump
over the third one and land right now
how do i get past this
how did it hit me i wasn't even looking
spikes come get you if you stay there
too long hey but
what the i'm waiting at the next level
and i just died because of jimmy
what do i do try not dying what if jimmy
has to do it because he can't get past i
got it i got it okay
okay now you guys don't get the gist of
the game this thing is incredibly hard
now here's the thing
if you can get to the 10th level you
pass
that's what the challenge but if you
can't get to the 10th level
you have to get slimed slimes wait no
if you don't get to the 10th level you
have to get slimed you boys have 30
minutes good luck
jimmy i'm stuck i don't know where to go
from here where are you at
i'm on level four you're on level four
how chris
it's so fast what am i supposed to do
i just i just want to know why let's go
why how do you beat level 2 i hate touch
screen more than you can
understand yeah touch screen is so bad
that's why this is hard oh
oh i beat the third level a what
come on i gotta restart great
oh my gosh is one of you hacking me
oh oh what do you do about the third
level i don't understand
how do you get in the ball what's the
furthest level you guys have gotten to
i'm on level four level four oh oh
what chris how do you get past the spike
wall on four
i think you have to do uh a very risky
wait why are you helping him i don't
know why did i tell him what are you
talking about no nothing not talking
about nothing
i'm gonna flip how about what if i flip
chris yes
i'm at the end of round three and the
wall just falls and hits me what do i do
um
get better maybe
oh i did it no come on
i don't even understand the next one how
i'm not telling
ignore my balls oh no
that was so close ah
oh my honk baby
i don't understand i'm at the end of
level three what do i do
jimmy you gotta trigger the wall and
then jump in the air off the edge and
jump back on
so you what go away notifications
guys it's a cry pov are you crying it's
about to be
oh oh i figured it out what it fooled me
it'll do that if you sit there too long
i get it now what
oh shoot was i supposed to be on that
little crevice i was
how oh my gosh this is impossible on an
iphone
especially on the boulder man why
what is hitting me
[Music]
no they always come straight for me it's
like they're targeting me
and you guys believe that some people
play this game for fun
no chance anybody does that look the
balls come for me for no reason
so we buy me a new phone hey carl
yes you hear chris raging yeah yeah
don't you think he should just get good
jimmy how's level three treating you i'm
on level four thank you very much
oh level six pog
let's go i made it on five yeah
i swear to god if the back button look
at all this
space why why would they put so much
space there
oh my i how do you get past level four i
figured out how to beat level five and
i'm starting to understand level six but
i just got game over
i'm not telling anybody how to do five
everybody just be quiet i'm trying to
concentrate
what i can't dude
ow carl how do you be five please oh i
almost beat six
cool now now i'm stuck at three again
that's cool i thought you said it was
easy
it is except for the controls are [ __ ]
bad i'm gonna break my phone
wait what the heck what am i supposed to
do
you guys are gonna cry on six
i finally figured out how to beat five
you guys are gonna
freak out on six i'm telling you right
now i can't even express it
what's the highest level you've been to
chandler i'm on five currently
chandler's highest is five chris is five
carls is six minus four
carl why are these orange things
spawning on level five i don't i have no
idea i think that means you're taking
too long
oh i beat it i beat it yeah the next
one's even harder
chandler how's your day going this is
the worst game i've ever played in my
freaking life
ah no okay
come on carl come on carl you're a gamer
you know this
oh i like i know what i need to do but
the controls are so bad
it doesn't make any sense the ball goes
not in the geometrically
correct way it just goes wherever the it
wants
it's guarding the exit it is and you
swear to god the balls just guard the
exit
yes i did it oh my god oh i remember
this
i remember this from the pewdiepie video
with the ending for six you just die
like what am i supposed to do oh my god
dude i'm so stressed out
ah how do you go oh my gosh six is
impossible
oh i was so close i was so close to
being six
oh i know how to do six now how do you
beat floor number five someone please
come in imagine being on four
five yeah i'm gonna go work with
chandler i'll be right back chris don't
say anything
all right all right all right this is
how we win i literally
jumped up coming over here to get cheats
how do you beat it the only way i've
made it through is go all the way to the
end spam 100 balls and then just drop
in between them wait can you do more
than one oh oh there we go now i know
all right thanks for helping get out of
my way notification
oh my cringe ah
the balls hit you dude i just i'm sad
i don't wanna i swear to god
game over no
i made it to eight wait i'm almost
cleared
wait i know i'm not at the studio but do
you guys hear do you guys yeah i think
it's a ambulance
why not have some physics in your game
is it because you don't have physics
controls you can program it okay right
here right here right here
right here right here
i give up i'll just get slimed we are
now going to turn off the ipad
and we're gonna just take it and we're
just gonna drop it and we're never gonna
play the game again
ah just just join me and getting slimed
one more see how much stress you're
under just just take the slime to the
face it's not worth this
i'm on level 8. i
hate this game
[Music]
no i've accepted the slime i don't care
i wouldn't play that game for a million
dollars
if you're the creator of this game and
you're watching this video i'm sorry but
i hate you
i'm starting to think the slime might be
refreshing
what the f was that i'm on nine i'm on
nine
remember oh wait why would they change
up the float
i mean frick holy [ __ ]
chris chris yes no one just gets slammed
no
i don't but you have five minutes left
until you're joining me and getting
slapped
well then i'm gonna go out fighting like
a true warrior gamer because i'm wearing
the mr beast gaming merch and that means
i try
everyone who hasn't been to level 10 in
the next five minutes will join me in
getting slimed
oh my god i got to the ending of level
9.
so far me and chandler have given up
we're accepting the slime will carl and
chris join us in getting slimed
i'm not gonna get slimed i'm not gonna
get slimed why is it different every
time i've literally done it
30 times in a row and now it's just
different okay i got it i'm on i'm on
level seven 30 seconds remaining carl
what level are you on
carl did you throw your phone i got game
over at the end of level nine
well perfect timing because 10 seconds
remain five
four three two
one stop gamers chris did you make it to
level ten
um yeah i'm almost there here let me see
let me see
this yeah all right eat through it
through the device
chris failed i failed chandler failed
and
carl failed correct carl yeah correct
all right boys i'm gonna go start mixing
the slime see in a minute
we have our bucket of slime here and the
boys we'll start off with carl
oh here's a little bit for you oh it's
so
warm
this is drenched all right thank you for
watching subscribe